when I began my career in cancer
research really nothing was known about
how the disease arises and now we know
exactly why cancer occurs we don't know
all the causes which is a problem but we
do know that once those causes have done
their job all cancer arises from the
malfunction of genes
our owl sarcoma virus was discovered by
Peyton Rous at the turn of the 20th
century and was the first tumor my
receiver described to any credible level
it was a historic discovery and it was
utterly neglected for over 50 years
he took a tumor lyse the cells put it
through a filter to take out any living
cells
put that lysate or filtrate as we called
it into chickens and they would get the
same tumor and he could make extracts
from that tumor filter it put it in
another chicken and get a tumor again
hence Rous sarcoma virus and did it
bother me that it was a chicken virus
not at all I was a great believer in
what we call the universality of nature
and if I could find out anything about
cancer and a chicken I knew it would
apply to humans and boy was I right
there was something in the DNA of normal
avian cells that was Amala ggest to the
oncogene that the cancer gene of Rous
sarcoma virus we called it cell Sark for
the sake of the argument by the time I
gave my Nobel lecture I had a slide with
something like 30 retro viral oncogenes
each of which had a demonstrable
proto-oncogene progenitor if you will in
normal cells and as they as the number
mounted it became clear that here was it
was the makings of a fun of a unifying
theory of cancer and we were cautious
about how he stated that publicly at
first but by the early 80s I was using
that term a unifying theory of how all
cancers come about it was a gradually
building thrill to realize that we had
the cancer cell by the neck and his
terms of understanding it not in terms
of throttling it but in terms of
understanding it
you